Thrun classics what's in a storing like
me doing in a place like this I think
we're gonna find out over the next hour
why I'm so attracted to this this sort
of work
this and thanks for coming out today
this is year two of what I call the Yale
Nile initiative which is an excuse to
talk about history and paleo climate
altogether around not just the now River
Basin but more broadly as well and I am
really thrilled to be able to welcome
Joe McConnell from the desert Research
Institute I'm here today to kind of kick
us off this year Joe is a research
professor in the hydrology division of
the desert Research Institute very well
known to everyone in ice core science
kind of broadly real pioneer and
continuous flow analysis his lab is
really famous for having two icp-ms
a--'s which when I see these things as
in a store and they're kind of magic
boxes these things these are amazing
machines and I think the only lab in the
world that allows real data to be
visualized or data to be visualized in
real time which is spectacular I'm
taking some of my students out there in
about three weeks and we're really
excited to go out there and have fun
with ice core analysis hey Joe besides
just basic ice core science of course
the last few years she's gotten hooked
on doing history and archaeology and
were really grateful in the ancient
history community for all kinds of
reasons
it's Michael Segal a postdoc in Joe's
lab and Joe as an author as well in
nature from three years ago on a new
chronology of volcanic eruptions in
Antarctic and Greenland ice that
revolutionized pre-industrial history I
think it's one of the most important
papers in ancient history in decades I
think I make all my students read it
because it's fundamentally a few months
ago in the Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences this fundamentally
interesting paper lead pollution
recorded in Greenland ice indicates
European emissions attract plagues Wars
and imperial expansion during antiquity
this is a phenomenally interesting paper
it's lit up the world
of Iron Age archeology and a particular
Roman historians and it really is court
of a first sort of paper that's going to
generate I think years of research in
Roman history and the first millennium
BC world's let alone work in ice core
analysis so with that as a brief
introduction I will turn the floor over
to dr. Joel McConnell okay can you hear
me okay yeah thank you all for coming
and thanks to Joe Manning for the
invitation I was telling Brian Skinner a
minute ago that I first set foot in on
Yale campus and in this lecture hall 40
years ago this month hard to believe and
it was to hear Brian give his
introductory geology class so anyway who
would have thought I'd be here talking
about history but anyway ok so I'm going
to talk about ancient the titled zinc's
in history and ice I have two primary
collaborators on the work that I'm going
to talk about Andrew Wilson some of you
historians may know him at Oxford and
Andreya Stoll is a very well known
atmospheric modeler in Norway at the
Norwegian Institute of polar research
sorry err research and then we had other
co-authors a couple of people Monica and
Nathan from my group Sabina Eckart from
neela as well a couple more people from
Oxford Elizabeth and mark Pollard and
then JP Steffensen from the University
of Copenhagen definitely a very much a
collaborative effort funding always have
to acknowledge the funding so most of
the work that I do is funded by NSF some
by NASA but most of my NSF Arctic and
Antarctic programs I've made about 25
trips to the green to Greenland over the
last 25 years and about more than 10
trips to Antarctic for these funded by
these programs so the specific work most
of the specific work I'm going to be
talking about today was funded by the
John Feld fund at Oxford and
the desert Research Institute my
Institute so some of you may know some
of the historians may know that in the
90s people measured lead in ice in
Greenland ice Rossmann at all in 97 and
hung at all in 94 and they published
this record this was the Rossman record
so this is concentration these are
isotopes on this axis and you can see
that during you know a thousand BC to
1600 ad it looks like and you can see
there was this increase during the the
Greek and Roman period and it dropped in
the isotopes and this created a lot of
buzz in the history and historian world
about what information you could get
from ice and as a result of that well
this is just another graph of the same
data the same concentration points and
so these guys measured 18 measurements
over this 18 nineteen hundred year
period and each measurement represented
what they thought was two years of ice
so that was the record that historians
were using for these these studies of
Roman economy and the Greek economy and
so forth
and after that so the the Andrew Wilson
and mark Pollard from Oxford came to me
because they knew I could measure led
very accurately in ice and this is the
record that we developed and this is
what I'm going to be talking sort of
around and about today and you can see
you get a very different picture of of
lead pollution in Greenland from this
much much higher resolution record and
so our measurements have instead of
having 18 we have 21,000 measurements
across the same time period and we have
about twelve measurements per year
during antiquity okay so it's a very
different record that in gives you a
much different picture but you can see
that the average concentrations are
pretty much an agreement there it's very
much an agreement with the previous work
so an outline of what I'm going to talk
about because this is kind of a mixed
audience of Earth scientists and
historians I thought I'd kind of try to
Fred thread the needle between the two
I'm gonna talk about the archive of past
environmental change in glacier ice just
to kind of bring you up to speed with
that and then I'm going to talk about
continuous my record during antiquity
the specific
paper that Joe referred to and then some
conclusions and future plans so imagine
you're standing on an ice sheet there's
snow falling around you it's gonna pile
up around your feet and it's going to be
very low-density fluffy stuff as it as
time goes by it's gonna start to age and
be buried and that's going to form a
surface layer that's harder and more
compact eventually this thing is going
to squeeze down trapping air bubbles and
then and then the ice and eventually at
about 60 to 110 meters depending on the
site you're gonna turn from a fern or
old snow into ice so you're going to
close the pores off the air bubbles off
and then you're going to trap at that
point some picture of the atmosphere at
that time right and these are the the
seminal records that you hear about and
climate change science of carbon dioxide
and carbon monoxide and methane so
really fundamental cornerstones of
climate change science well different
than that are is that what's in the
precipitation itself so that's the water
isotopes and water isotopes we use as a
proxy of temperature of site temperature
very well known again very much a
cornerstone of climate change science
comparing especially water isotopes to
the gas records right in addition to
that you get sea spray you get aerosol
so-called aerosols and by aerosols I
mean very small droplets or particles
that are in the air all around us they
come from in the natural world things
like sea spray and dust and then in the
more recent period maybe the last three
thousand years you get pollutants and so
I'm just going to show you this quick
little a little part of the simulation
this is a simulation from NASA and it's
a simulation of aerosols moving around
the earth some of you may have seen it
in this you can see down here sea salts
are color coded blue desert dust is red
organic and black carbon is green and
then the sulfates in white and just as
you're watching it you know you can see
things coming off of biomass burning
plumes in Africa and South America you
can see dust coming off the Sahel in the
Sahara and you can see pollutants and so
forth and I won't read it for very long
I don't think let's see this
work I personally find this very
mesmerizing it's kind of like watching a
fire you know you can see everything
kind of swirling around so you can see
the as an example you can see the big
sea salt storms circulating and circling
Antarctica
alright sweeping around there you can
see sulfates coming off of the
industrial parts of the North America
Western Europe and and Asia you can see
here's the dust dust swirls coming off
of the Sahel and sweeping out over the
Atlantic and fertilizing it and then
watch here you see these these big
biomass burning plumes coming off of
these regions now some of that aerosol
you're not much of it have quite a small
percentage of it uh actually ends up
getting swept up over the Greenland and
Antarctic continents and gets deposited
with the precipitation or gets dry
deposited onto the snow and gets buried
and that's what we measure with the ice
core right so and then every once in a
while just to make sure everybody's on
the same page every once in a while you
get a nuclear explosion which we know
very well about in Nevada you get a
nuclear explosion or you get a cosmic
ray burst in the upper atmosphere or you
get volcanic eruption that creates a
sulphur to increase in sulphur in the
atmosphere and those get deposited all
around the earth pretty much at the same
time and that gives you an I so Kron
then we can then use for cross dating
ice cores we can use it for confirming
our dating and we can use it for
synchronizing to other archives things
like lake sediments or ocean sediments
and things like that so yeah so then we
go draw an ice core you can see we're
just going to drill an ice core from the
top to the bottom the ice at the top is
the age of when we drilled the ice core
here so whatever date we started
drilling and it's just going to go down
however far I think the longest ice core
is about 3.4 kilometers long so they're
just gonna penetrate ice down 3.4
kilometers for a couple of miles this is
just a quick schematic of what a glacier
and ice sheet looks like in this case an
ice sheet so you can divide it into sort
of two zones the accumulation zone so
that's where you're in positive surface
mass balance so more snow is falling out
of the sky
then is melting and so you got a that's
where you're building up layers year
after year after year you have the
ablation zone where that the opposite is
the case you have negative mass balance
in order to keep this thing at steady
state you have to transport through flow
ice flow you have to transport mass from
the accumulation zone into the ablation
zone so you can imagine normally we
would go to the accumulation zones to
drill ice cores because we want layers
piling up year after year we don't want
we don't wanna be missing years or we
don't wanna have negative mass balance I
should add that these days there is
quite a bit of work going on in the
ablation zones and that's because you
don't have to drill through hundreds or
thousands of meters of snow to get to
the old stuff the old stuff is exposed
right at the surface so if you want big
samples we typically nowadays you go to
the ablation zones you can imagine it's
very difficult to date this ice it's
very there's a lot of flow distortion
and then there's also the dating issue
but there is quite a bit of work going
on in that area so so I just thought I'd
say a little bit about sampling the
archive so that you can imagine I divide
it up into three three different methods
of sort of scales the deep sampling is
this is a Millenial scaler multi-male
neol scale work this is an example at
stipple dome so these are big projects
might take four to five six years they
usually involve multiple institutions
and often involve multiple countries the
big operations cost tens of millions of
dollars this is another example from the
danish group the danes do a lot of
drilling in greenland because of their
historical connection to greenland this
is the campus in 2011 at neem and so
this is the geodesic dome they had built
and it's pretty neat you live in this
thing this is the galley you don't work
in this part you just live here and
recreative now put this thing on skis
and so they can drag it around the ice
sheet so this has been dragged to the
other side of the ice sheet and it's now
being used in the egret project anyway
it's a really neat building and I'm
amazed that they're able to drag it
across the ice sheet but you can see a
c-130 IUS el c-130 there a ski plane and
that's for the heavy lift capacity to
provide the logistics for the camp now
most of the work as I said we just
recreation this building most of the
work actually happens in trenches and
these are you know maybe 30 feet or ten
meters deep that are using you
snowblower to make them and then you
cover them over you can see the
advantages or the disadvantage is that
it's cold and you feel like a troglodyte
in there the advantage though is the
weather can be doing anything upstairs
and you have no idea what it is so you
can work in any environments this is the
deep drill so this drill will eventually
go down 2.8 kilometers and then Phi and
then intermediate sampling would be what
maybe 100 to 200 meter long course and
by the way the total depth is 200 meters
we handle it in typically one meter
sections so anyway the and I die my
group has done a lot of this kind of
work including the Arctic Circle
Traverse where we went by snow will be
across Greenland collecting ice cores
and doing radar surveys might take you
let's say a few days to a week or two to
drill to a 100 to 200 meter core and
then I've also done some work this is
with the Australians at Aurora Basin in
East Antarctica and you can see this is
the camp there the the buildings where
we work and these are all a sleeping
tents everybody has their own sleeping
tent to have some privacy and get away
from people a little bit supplied by not
by c-130 but supplied by Basler aircraft
as a DCO stretched dc-3 and then this
has been the drilling operation so this
very small little drilling town again
invented a little bit into the snow this
is the old surface right here and a tent
so you can work in any environment and
you can see this is Christmas dinner
it's not too bad life is pretty good we
got wine we got pretty good shape and
then if you're really good Santa Claus
will show up and you can you've got to
be good anyway and then there's sampling
shallow sampling and my group is this
was originally what we sort of
specialized in and these would be maybe
30 meter cores maybe you're looking at a
decade's to maybe one century long
record and you can this is a technique
that I developed called commuter Corning
and the reason was that when we first
started doing this we would get taken
out by a ski plane the twin otter like
this on skis we'd get dropped off of all
of our camping gear plane would go away
and a couple days
later if we're lucky they come back and
get us but at one point in time we were
had the beginning of a project we got
her we are on our fourth of eight sites
and we got stuck for a week at a site
and our generator was giving out and our
stoves were giving out it was
touch-and-go anyway so I came up with
this idea of keeping that twenty million
dollar plane and the pilots with us so
they don't get to leave and they're not
going to leave us out there in that
situation so the key is to be home in
time for dinner and then weigh if you're
if you're stuck in or whatever by the
weather or by broken planes or whatever
you're stuck on the coast so it's much
safer and it's actually cheaper because
you're flying out full of ice of empty
ice core boxes and camping gear and so
forth you get dropped off you do your I
mean you don't get dropped off you do
your work and you fly back light on fuel
and heavy on ice cores so it only takes
one round-trip instead of two round
trips those NASA loved us because of
this now you can imagine you're a pilot
or a co-pilot and you're sitting up
there and you're it's about minus 25
minus 30 and you think well what am I
going to do you can sit in the plane and
watch us and get really cold or you can
help us and so there's the copilot the
pilot it makes a big difference
especially when you get a really big
strong Danish pilot who can lift our
co-pilot he could lift anything so ice
core analysis I just thought I'd say a
little bit about ice core analysis so in
the old days as in this record we were
talking about earlier from Rossman these
were their 18 points that they measured
over this nineteen hundred year period
right eighteen measurements two years
each now why would they measure so
little make so few measurements
fundamental question right well the
reason was because they were doing
discrete sample analysis and from metals
very very low levels of metals they were
loading up a piece of ice right here
into a into a lathe that's a hand lathe
and they were scraping very carefully by
hand they were chiseling off ice and
catching it in this little bucket so
they're all dressed up in their clean
gear and all that sort of thing on
working under a laminar bench and so
forth and they're slowly scraping this
off and you know progressively working
their way towards the that could
uncontaminated inner part of the ice
you can imagine hugely time-intensive
I've been told that it took some of my
hyung and colleagues up to six months to
make to chisel those eighteen samples
it's a big deal right
we have gotten around that now and
that's why we have this so many more
samples like this by using continuous
analysis and Joe alluded to it a minute
ago
so continuous analysis rather than
discrete and in this case we're going to
use well so let's back up a little bit
so here's the cylindrical core so you
can imagine a cylindrical core about 10
centimeters in diameter a meter long
we're gonna cut from that approximately
three point three by three point three
centimeter by a hundreds of one meter
long 100 centimeter long stick of ice
it's like this long stick and we can cut
in one project we actually cut seven of
those sticks from one 10 centimeter core
so we can analyze the core over and over
again we don't use anywhere near hold
the ice on one analysis then we're gonna
clean the ends very carefully as you can
see here for those of you who know who
Michael Siegel is he's the hand model
here we're going to use this is a
ceramic potato peeler you can buy from
Amazon or whatever but but it's really
important that we get the ends really
clean and so ceramic is really the only
way to go we can get it clean enough for
these metals and then we're going to
load that stick so there's that stick I
was talking about we're gonna load it up
into this melter stand here that we
developed and the ice is just gonna fall
by gravity down onto this heated melter
plate I'll show you in a second here's
the melter plate down here it's just
going to fall by gravity the melter
plate is very the temperatures
controlled very carefully and that water
is going to melt and we're going to suck
it off and analyze it real time in about
a million dollars worth of analytical
equipment let's see
[Music]
so this is what the melter head looks
like and so you can see that about three
and a half three point three by three
point three centimeters stick of ice
it's on top of it these ridges that are
engraved into the melter head separate
the meltwater into different sections
the innermost 10% is what we analyzed
using those high-resolution icp-ms is
that Joe mentioned for elemental
measurements the next twenty percent or
so we're going to pump off into
different of a whole Bank of instruments
that we measure things like nitrate and
sulfate that's sorry nitrate and
ammonium and things that are water
isotopes things that are very difficult
to contaminate and occur at much higher
levels and then the final 70 percent the
outer seventy percent we're gonna throw
away is potentially contaminated so
instead of chiseling day after day month
after month we're going to use the
melter system to clean the ice to
decontaminate the ice so we're only
going to use that innermost 10% well the
difference is we don't have to chisel it
just we just happens in real time it's
fantastic
yeah so let me show you let's see where
are we next no so this is a schematic
and I won't bore you with the details
here but this is a schematic there's the
melter stand in the cold room falls down
onto the melter head we take that 10%
inner part and send it off to this it's
this kind of setup so the two icp-ms is
right here we collect fractions for
later on analysis if we want as an
archive and then the other part we send
over this direction in this particular
case I'm showing that this is our gaps
method we don't do the gas measurements
ourselves so we used to think of those
gases that were bubbling out of the
water we used to think of that as a
waste product and be annoyed by it
because we don't want those air bubbles
to go through our system but starting
about three or four years ago four or
five years ago now the Danes and the
French and the people at Oregon State
were developing methods to measure that
gas in in continuous mode as well and
it's all a function of technology its
cavity ring down measurement systems
that make it possible but so now we can
get methane and Co measurements
continuously as part of this whole thing
so out of that little stick of ice we
can get about 35 different measurements
of elements and chemical species and
then as well as the gases and the water
isotopes all out of that little 3x3
three point three by three point three
six
so it's really revolutionized this our
industry and that we can get so much
information out of so little ice and
that saves other rights for other
applications for those who are
interested this is sort of what we're
doing at the periodic table nowadays so
the ones that are in solid circles we
routinely measure so we're covering a
pretty good part of the periodic table
the ones that are dashed like plutonium
down here we only measure that under
special circumstances just as a little
aside to plutonium we published the
paper last year moved here before on
continuous measurements of plutonium and
so what we're doing that for is to try
to see the bomb pulses 53 to 54 to 63
period of thermonuclear testing and we
need that we'd like to know that for the
thermonuclear perspective but also for
dating ice cores and we came up with a
continuous method for that but the the
height of the peak of the bomb pulse
period is one part per quadrillion so
that's one gram in 10 to the fifteenth
grams of plutonium is extinct to make
that measurement is extremely sensitive
analytical equipment so so let me just
show you this little video of the lab
just to give you a picture worth a
thousand words kind of thing the first
couple of seconds is a green for some
unknown reason it'll change here so this
is Nathan my my PhD students working on
the core and so he's just shaving it
down to make sure it'll fit in the
melter stand so that's you know one
meter long about three and a three point
three by three point three in
cross-section you can imagine in the ice
we can't tell what's up or down so once
it's and until we analyze it and so we
want to keep up so up is all those to
the right and he's put that X in there
to mark the top of the core so we can
keep track of it it goes through the
melter and now he's cleaning the ends
very carefully because the ends are
gonna go into the melter system they're
not going to get thrown away as part of
that 70% so since that's going into the
analytical system we need it to be
really really clean very very clean so
he's done that now he's we've loaded it
up into the melter stand you can see the
ice poking out the top there it's
falling by gravity down onto the melter
head and slowly melting I should add
that the melter head is made out of a
ceramic a silica carbide so you can
clean it with konk acid and all that
we do routinely this is it sped up
obviously but there's the ice falling
through the melter head and there's time
right there and you can see that
Nathan's whipping in there he's very
fast and yeah you can just see the ice
and so you can imagine we get we can
generate data incredibly quickly
compared to the old days
in fact my group is sort of swimming in
data we can't the group is not big
enough to publish all these data in a
timely way so if you need data talk to
me so anyway so then you can see the
water is being pumped in the air bubbles
and so forth are being pumped into
different analytical systems when my
students first sort of postdocs first
see this they freaked out because of all
that spaghetti but after you get used to
it it's pretty clear how it works so you
can see all that gas water mixture is
getting pumped through the whole system
and then we go through bubble detectors
to determine the air water mixture we're
seeing and that sort of thing and those
of you in just seminar will see all this
and get to scrape ice yourselves here
soon and then in this case we're doing
gases so you can see the bubbles going
into that 1d bubbler and that sealed so
the gas is going out the top okay so I
hope I've covered that first part what
the archive is how its formed some of
the issues you know accumulation versus
ablation zone that kind of thing how we
sample that with different different
scales and then our discreet versus
continuous analysis so now I thought I'd
talk a little about a little bit about
this lead during antiquity story and
it's there are some extremely important
steps in all this so I'm not just going
to go straight to the record so this is
the paper that Joe alluded to or
mentioned and it was as I said earlier
it was collaboration with historians at
Oxford archaeologists at Oxford our
group the Norwegian Institute for air
research and the University of
Copenhagen and their main contributions
they provided us with the ice so a very
important contribution
so first of all so the question we're
gonna ask is why does Greenland lead
well what does Greenland lead pollution
tell us about ancient economies during
antiquity first question who cares right
well I hope this audience cares I hope I
don't have to convince you but certainly
ancient has an economic historians a
political scientists and archeologists
would like to know some quantitative
information about ancient economies and
what what controlled that were what
drove increases and decreases in
economic activity so oops sorry has
environmental scientists of course we'd
also like to know you know we'd like to
know assess human impacts and the idea
that humans were having a measurable
impact on the environment 2,000 or 3,000
years ago is not something that you kind
of take lightly
why lead well led it turns out was that
most of the silver that existed in most
of the silver that was mined by the
Romans and they and they wanted silver
for their coinage because they were a
silver based coinage most of that silver
occurred as lead and Galena ores so led
silver combination and pretty much sort
of rule of thumb for every gram of
silver they produced they produced 99
grams of lead and led with this lower
boiling point was easily a lot of it was
scaped and was into the atmosphere was
emitted into the atmosphere and
transported around the earth another
nice thing about lead is has very low
background levels in the natural
environment the other sort the other
primary sources would be dust
continental dusts or just the lead
occurring in dust or rock and then also
bucket some volcanic eruptions have
significant amount of lead in them the
other thing as I mentioned we have a
little bit is we have very low detection
limits so when we were doing this
experiment you know we can redesign we
can reconfigure this depending on our
what our scientific objectives are in a
particular project in this case we took
this low resolution icp-ms and we only
is that for LED measurements actually
thallium lead and bismuth was the suite
and by doing that we were able to get
lots and lots of measurements and end up
with a detection limit on the order of
about 0.01 picograms per gram so that's
10 to the minus 12 grams per gram so a
very very low levels and very important
for this kind of work
as I mentioned I think we analyzed a
total of four hundred and twenty three
meters of archived North grip - ice for
this project
alright Joe Morgan cannot answer this
question although it'd be a good test to
see if he is paying attention last fall
so so anybody want to hazard a guess of
what the three most important words and
paleo environmental work is anybody all
right I won't make you do it dating
dating and dating and this is a quote
from Jeff stirring house I don't know
whether he lifted it from someone else
and this is important especially if
you're going to try to do accurate you
need accurate independent dating
especially if you're gonna try to infer
causality so you see a change in the in
the ice core record or some other
archive you see a change in history if
you're gonna say one is somehow linked
to the other implying causality boy you
better make sure you're dating is
completely independent because if it's
not you're just tuning to get the
correlation right so really really
important dating is absolutely critical
so I'm gonna say a little bit about that
so this is a one meter section from 380
to 381 meters depth in the ice core in
the North group to ice core and I've
plotted a bunch of different parameters
so ammonium and sea salt sodium in green
non-si south calcium in purplish I guess
the magenta something and then the two
LED measurements from the two icp-ms is
in in the blues and then I've plotted
just to emphasize it I've plotted an on
sea salt sulfur - sea salt sodium ratio
and that's the one we could use for
dating so would anybody like to hazard a
guess as to how many years you see
across this remember there's an annual
cycle and all those chemist chemicals so
right so one meter and and we've got
clearly one annual cycle - annual cycle
three four five right so if we date this
again we're just going to start at the
top and we're just going to count
backwards these annual cycles we're
going to count them backwards
so here's 80 1980 1880 17 and so forth
and you can see it's very clear the
annual cycles in this section are very
clear I mean there's not really a lot of
debate so we dated this ice core
completely not completely independently
from 12 59
the eruption of Somalis in Indonesia a
very distinctive marker and ice cores we
measured we started there and we just
counted backwards one year at a time for
the whole record all the way back to
about 1200 BC so 20 but whatever that is
3,300 years something like that
I mean 35 anyway so that's that's how we
date it and we're gonna in this case we
use the midwinter
non sea salt sulfur - sea salt sodium
minimum that we could see in the ice
right so we just arbitrarily assigned
this date of January 1st every year and
that's how we date the core we'd also
like to be able to evaluate those
chronologies in some way so the dating
of the ice core referred to as a
chronology we'd like to be able to date
it in some independent way and the way
we do that is we compare it to beryllium
10 and we can do it turns out with link
to the tree ring records - the ice core
records through cosmogenic nuclides and
that would be 10 beryllium and ice and C
14 in wood we can do this at annual
scales using these very high frequency
one to two year events that were
reported by Miyake originally in nature
and Michael Siegel that Joe mentioned
that Michael Siegel was really took this
and ran with it or we can do it into
Keadle time scales published by Adelphia
Mishler their techniques and the
advantage is that we can then look at
the ice core chronology that we
developed and we can try to do something
we can evaluate it and try it
independently and try to assess the
uncertainties in the ice core dating and
I'm not going to go into too much detail
but we did this so this is our our age
scale - the Intel tree ring age scale
and what you see there gray is their
their one sigma uncertainty in their
dating and you can see that our are
dating fits within their one there nor
one sigma so from that we infer that
we've got about a plus or minus two year
maximum dating uncertainty in our record
so to say to a historian I think it's
safe to say to say to a historian or
certainly to an archaeologist that you
have one to two year uncertainty in your
dating 2,000 years ago is a pretty nice
thing and we also did that with the
Rossman at all or the Huong at all
dating those 18 points we evaluated
their age scale and age scales has AB
evolved a lot in the last 30 years as
you can imagine and it turned out that
they were about 30
years off so historians were using that
information to infer things and not only
were there hardly any samples but they
were also miss dated by about 30 years
in antiquity so things have been proved
another question has led provenance
so archaeological evidence suggests that
Western Europe and China were the sort
of the two possibilities for where these
emissions could be coming from so the
question is how do we know this is
European lead and not Egyptian not
Chinese lead right and the way we know
that well first of all we built on
rossmann Rosslyn's results so rossmann
Kevin Rossmann had measured the isotopes
in those 13 samples as I showed you at
the beginning and then if you plot it on
208 over 207 and 206 over 207 and you
plotted in this space you can see that
they kind of fall along this line right
here and these circles represent
different sources different ore bodies
in Europe and it looks like you know all
these measurements are consistent with a
mixing model of European lead so there's
we can't say it is lead it's from Europe
what we can say is it's consistent with
Europe right so it could be coming from
China still based on just the isotopic
evidence alone so we took that idea and
we kind of well first of all I mean let
me say so possible emissions sites are
in Western Europe in China during
antiquity central Greenland up here is a
long way from those lead silver mines in
in antiquity down in Europe so we're
looking at basically transport from down
here all the way up to Greenland
so long-range transport is implicit of
course is even longer from China right
so we can use a very much
state-of-the-art atmospheric model to
investigate this this is this flex part
model that andreas stole and to be an
aircard contributed way to do this kind
of modeling basically you have a source
receptor so if you're doing it in the
forward direction you start with the
source say the lead emissions and you
have the receptors out there and you
transport the lead from the source to
the receptors you can run it in backward
mode as well and look at the sort
receptor to source relationship we need
to have a very very detailed atmospheric
fields to do this kind of work and of
course they don't exist for antiquity so
we used the 20th century reanalysis
fields and assume that the meteorology
was basically the same
at least at the large-scale so this is
the result this is the ice core sitting
right here in the circle and this is
where we model the emissions coming from
down in here and this is these in this
in backward mode so this is this
receptacle source and what we found was
that n group to the I square site was
about 10 times more sensitive to
European emissions than it is to Chinese
emissions so it is possible that you're
getting Chinese emissions but they would
have to be extremely large to overwhelm
the Greenland signal all right so you
can see a China over here they're very
small numbers and we're bigger numbers
in here so so from that we think that we
think between the isotopes Oh is one
more one more slide on that we also
looked at the fallout pattern as you
moved away from the emissions areas that
proved the the hypothesized emissions
down here and we looked at peat bog
records published peat bog records as
she moved away from this we would expect
that to drop off more or less
exponentially as you move away from the
source and that is indeed what we found
you can see the black or the different
speed sorry peat bog records and the red
is our records so it looks like there's
it behaves as though the source is in
southern Europe we also wanted to do for
the first time in ice core study I think
we wanted to use the atmospheric
modeling to assess how much in how much
variability we would see in deposition
just from the atmospheric transport
alone so we use the same Flex part
modeling and what you come up with is a
year-to-year difference in atmospheric
transport results in about a 60%
coefficient of variation in the amount
of lead that's deposited so even if you
had a constant source in southern Europe
by the time you transport in deposit in
Greenland it's going to have about a 60%
year-to-year variability in the
deposition if you apply an 11-year
median filter to it you preserve the
medium filter will preserve step
functions but you'll knock down a lot of
that variability and again up was about
a 22 percent coefficient of variation so
in the paper we always used a narrow bar
of plus or minus 22% when we talk about
the lead record
why Greenland why go to Greenland to do
this you might think going to the to the
Alps would make more sense helps are
much closer and so forth but unlike
Greenland alpine glaciers unlike
Greenland ice sheet alpine glaciers are
very thin and they have complex flow
histories so if you get down to ancient
history if you get down a thousand or
two thousand years ago the layers are
extremely thin I mean millimeters or sub
millimeter thick layers making dating
difficult independent dating difficult
and I would argue impossible it also
makes it because there's still little
material you can't do that 10 beryllium
sort of cosmogenic nuclei did sort of
comparison there's just not enough
material and so it makes it very
difficult to quantitatively assess how
good those chronologies are and then
finally sites can be very heavily
influenced by in europe can be very
heavily influenced by small nearby
emissions and this is just an example of
that so this is that same flex part
modeling but this time for an ice core a
theoretical ice core from cold the dome
on my bunk in the French Alps and you
can see on the scale here we're fifty to
a hundred times more sensitive to
emissions right around the Alps then we
would be to emissions from Spain so you
can get a record but there's a pretty
good chance that record is going to be a
local record of emissions from a nearby
mine mine down the bottom of the valley
below the ice core site so there are
some advantages in going far away
whereas well we're in Greenland up here
we're seeing sort of continental wide
emissions because there of course are no
emission sources anywhere near Greenland
particularly at this time ok so let me
just walk you through the interpretation
of the record so two thing well first of
all we've we've switched from total lead
to lead pollution and we did that on the
vertical axis and we did that by
subtracting the component of dust so we
measure a dust tracer and we used the
crustal abundance to subtract the dust
potential the potential dust component
and then we used and we then we also has
to mate a volcanic component not a big
deal it's about 13% of the total
measured lead is what we subtracted so
it's not a big part of the signal we are
also going to convert we also converted
from constant
raishin to flux so we're looking at
depositional flux onto the ice by
multiplying by the water accumulation
the concentration times of water
accumulation and then we're also going
to use the Flex part modeling to convert
we could convert it and we did in the
paper from lead pollution in Greenland
to estimate it let emissions in Europe
and we can do that with the sensitivity
modeling for one kilogram per second of
lead emission in southern Spain the
model would suggest you'd get 12.9 on
average twelve point nine micrograms per
meter squared of lead deposited in
central Greenland so we can use the lead
pollution record to reconstruct
european-wide emissions granted with
some estimate with some assumptions but
so anyway so at 0.75 micrograms per
meter squared per year of pollution in
Greenland would equate to 1.8 kilotons
per year of emissions and it turns out
the archeological estimates were pretty
darn close to this I think they were
maybe within 50% of that number so gives
you a nice warm and fuzzy right our
record goes from in this case we're
going from 1100 BC to 800 AD so for
those non historians in the audience
that's the Iron Age through classical
and late antiquity
into the early Middle Ages that includes
the rise and fall of the Greek and Roman
empires as well as the migration what we
used to call the dark ages and I think
now is called the migration period so
let's just walk through it a little bit
so you can see this first rise back here
well what was that and we can't say this
is what it was but it is at least coeval
with the Phoenician expansion of trading
from the eastern Mediterranean towards
the western Mediterranean right you can
see that the concentration goes up he
initially here the bounces up and down
excuse me by by coincidence this big
jump happens at around the time that
Alexander the Great
consolidated power we didn't talk about
that in the paper because we really
didn't have a very good explanation for
why that would have changed let
emissions but anyway it rises up you
could see some big drops and then right
here that you see this big bite out of
the record and here it rises and drops
rapidly it stays down for about 80 or a
hundred years and then it jumps back up
here stays high and then it falls
dramatically right here and eventually
reaches a nadir right here so what are
those what do they correspond to in
history
and if we compare them it turns out that
this corresponds to the crisis of the
Roman for a public so this is the end of
the Roman Republic when everybody's
fighting each other in their civil wars
Marc Antony and Cleopatra here at the
end and so forth and that represent a
very big dip in the lead pollution
record suggesting a much lower
production of silver at least in a spot
in the Iberian Peninsula so you had this
big drop and then in the third century
this other dip corresponds to the third
century crisis of Imperial Rome another
another period of political and still an
instability and military hierarchy right
so very nicely the two big bites out of
the record fit very nicely with what we
know about history during this period in
between those two crises was the Parkes
Romana and I'm not sure if that's an
accepted phrase and that the history
world but for us dia fights it is anyway
so yeah this is the period the parker
mata is a period of the ger differs from
Caesar Augustus through Marcus Aurelius
approximately 27 BC to AD 180 and you
can see that during that period
emissions were quite high and fairly
stable indicating substantial growth in
the Roman economy during the Imperial
period you can also notice if you look
carefully at it you can see that lead
pollution rose about ten years after the
beginning of the Puck's Romana after
imperial rule and Octavian becoming
Caesar Augustus and taking over
it took about 10-15 years for that to
rise maybe closer to ten I guess and
then it also drops the lead pollution
dropped quite dramatically
what about 15 years before the death of
Marcus Aurelius in the end of the parks
Romana so the question is why when
Andrew and I first saw this we were a
little bit puzzled by it it turns out
that it went avian took over as Caesar
Augustus he didn't immediately seize
control it took him about nine or ten
years to establish control over the
provinces and spent in Spain and Gaul
and exactly pretty much exactly when it
should let go shooting up and the reason
that is and we think it's because of
large-scale administrative changes that
follow this pacification so it's all
about organization all about getting us
into those mines and having a mind like
crazy and smelt like crazy right and it
does coincide this very immediate and
persistent increase in lead and then on
the other side on the other side this
drop on this side corresponds exactly I
mean to the year always keeping in the
back of your head plus or minus 1 to 2
years uncertainty of the age scale the
advent of the Antonine plague one of the
two that there were two great plagues in
Roman antiquity one was the Antonine
plague the other was the plague of
Cyprian and you can see we get this big
drop in 165 and andyc and the drop
continues to 193 more or less and that
was thought to be the smallpox killing
off roughly a third of the population of
the Roman Empire and then the very the
nadir of our record occurs here and that
exactly corresponds to the plague of
Cyprian which I think historians aren't
quite sure exactly what causes that but
again a big die-off the other great
plague of Roman antiquity it's a very
nice agreement with the historical
record there and then finally linking
back to the economy we've plotted silver
and Roman coinage so this is the amount
of silver per Roman denarii coin
Denarius coin and you can see that the
red so this is based on hoards
measurements and hoards and you can see
that the the coins the fineness and the
coins the silver content in the coins
drops off really pretty much in parallel
with our drop off and lead pollution and
what we would postulate is effectively a
tracer or an indicator of silver
production in the Roman Empire at least
from Spain especially and then it got so
bad that in the after the after the
plague of Cyprian the Romans abandoned
silver coinage at this point because and
went to a bronze and gold coin set up
again you can see the agreement is very
nice with our record so let me conclude
by saying I hope I've convinced you that
ice cores collected from glaciers and
ice sheets can contribute to historical
studies glaciers and one of the big
advantages of glaciers is they sort of
consistently and and objectively record
pollution that history environmental
history you know there's nobody making a
decision about land we wrote this or we
found the papyrus and the you know
of an animal or whatever there's nothing
like that it's a it's a pretty objective
recorder just sitting out there
recording information year after year
century after century it does have its
variability as I mentioned that 66 6
percent 6 my row is 60% coefficient of
variation but at least it's something we
can quantify and work with and evaluate
continuous measurements I think I'm sure
I hope I showed you that are much more
efficient and especially much more
cost-effective than discrete
measurements distal records do have some
advantages over a proximal particularly
at proximal to sources potential sources
atmospheric understand understanding the
atmospheric transport deposition is
really really important we feel and I
think is the future and then dating
dating and dating of course as usual and
then replication between sites and we
haven't replicated the Roman period yet
but we have replicated a lot of other
periods in the leg records and we get
very nice replication for the blood
record I've hope I hope I've convinced
you that led closely tracked historical
events during antiquity that periods of
social unrest coincided mostly with
downturns in pollution unrest definitely
but Wars sometimes increase sometimes
decreased plagues were especially
especially had a major impact the Pax
Romana contrary to the previous
interpretations on those 18 points the
PAC's Romana is seen now as a period of
strong economic growth and then finally
the silver in the Dinaric declined in
parallel in terms of future plans
obviously we would like to extend this
these records in this analysis in either
direction we'd like to go back from the
beginning of the iron via the Iron Age
back into the Bronze Age and the
collapse of the Bronze Age and all that
sort of thing and wait of course like to
go this way we're working on this
because we have these records but as
I'll see tell you in a minute we don't
have these records although we're
working on getting them we'd also like
to take the work that Jo Manning has
done and this is what we were talking
about yesterday and while we were eating
many times we were talking about
extending this this linkage between
explosive volcanism climate and ancient
history or historical events back and Jo
and in this paper he worked on Ptolemaic
Egypt
we'd like to of course go back in time
to the Bronze Age collapse and
and the New Kingdom and so forth well
you might say you might say well Joker's
go do it
Jose Jose just go do it but fundamental
to both of these objectives is
collection of and development of much
longer accurately dated records of these
score records right the problem in
Greenland ice cores is that you went and
you end up hitting them the brittle ice
the over-pressured brittle ice at about
600 meters which corresponds to about a
thousand bc roughly depending on the
site and when you hit that brittle ice
when you soon as you it's over pressured
you bring it up to the surface you drill
it you bring it up to the surface and if
you're not extremely careful and
sometimes even if you are extremely
careful it explodes and that's because
it's you know it's overpressure and some
explode well you can imagine for our
continuous analysis that makes it very
difficult to measure or impossible to
measure it so then you say well what
about all those coastal domes are small
Arctic Islands in the Arctic Ocean well
the problem there is those are like like
the Alpine course they tend to be
relatively thin and they thin too
rapidly to get any kind of independent
dating so we analyzed one from noosa
peninsula last year or two years ago and
the annual layer thickness at 0 1 ad
let's say is is on the order of a
millimeter thick so very difficult to to
date independent we can get a record but
we can't date it independently and if
you're going to do this historical work
that's what you need anyway thanks and
happy to take any questions and just for
you historians there's the famous Andrew
Wilson from Oxford helping his key came
out to the lab and helped us analyze the
core anyway thank you
[Applause]
questions comments come on you historian
thank you very much that was much above
my paygrade but I had a question about
what what can and can't be measured
would it be possible to measure ting
given that given its significance in the
creation of bronze and it's perhaps
being able to help with problems of
identifying where the tin was coming
from during the Bronze Age yeah it's a
good question
so when the when the Oxford people first
came to me they were really hoping we
could get copper because of the bronze
connection and it's a signal-to-noise
ratio issue so there's quite a bit of
copper out there in dust and seawater
and so forth
and so the background variability is
reasonably high and the pollution signal
is relatively low unlike LED you know
they're not producing they're not losing
that much copper we'd like to measure
still silver as well but again silver
has the same problem the signal-to-noise
ratio just isn't there now that said
Hong Hong reported measurements of
copper from those 18 samples he reported
measurements of copper but we measure
copper but we just don't see any any
signal yet now we could put more effort
into maybe that's what we'll do if we're
successfully getting funding to collect
more more cores and and tin by the way
sorry tin is in the same boat tin zinc
things like that have quite a high
background variability so detecting the
pollution signal is harder thank you
okay so arsenic again is a difficult one
we would have to it turns out that
arsenic has
isobaric interferences in the icp-ms so
we would have to dedicate one instrument
just arsenic if we were going to measure
arsenic we have measured antimony as a
kind of an indicator you know a proxy if
you will of arsenic and we don't see we
see a lot of recent antimony pollution
very clearly with the coal burning era
you can see big increases in antimony
but we don't see it in in this period
again I think it's a signal noise issue
and yeah maybe we'll redouble our
efforts to try to get it can you
simultaneously look for some climate
signals I mean there are some fairly
rapidly changing climate signals through
this thousand year period that you
described your can you look at that as
well somehow sure and I guess one of the
questions is so the focus of this study
was specifically on the lead pollution
as an indicator of the economy you could
imagine linking volcanoes or linking and
looking at water isotopes and things
like that to see if there were as any
evidence of climate drivers of some of
that instability so you have you know
the crisis of the Roman Republic was it
just societal or was there a climate
driver behind it certainly with all the
things we measure with you know dust for
heredity and black carbon for biomass
burning water isotopes and so forth we
measure a lot of things that you could
use we do use as climate proxies but we
haven't done that yet so actually it's
one of the things we were kind of
talking about
everyone's being very shy thank you that
was really fascinating and I'll confess
up front I haven't done science in a
very long time so please forgive me if
this is a silly question but I'm really
interested in the comments you made
about the the distant sources of ice and
more localized sources of ice and I'm
wondering if there's any way that the
more localized sources could perhaps
refine the picture or contribute to the
picture that you've given us here in any
meaningful way and is it the question
all basically revolves around are you
interested in those local sources or not
because the people out people for
instance have been looking and using
p-box to study the local sources of
pollution for decades and so that's the
question is sorry if you if you can see
through those local sources or if you're
interested in those local sources great
but if you're not there's always
sustained you're going to be swamped by
those local sources and then there's the
dating the dating question is huge right
I think a lot of the Alpine cores
basically then many of them offend to
the point where you can't see em you
can't even guess what the age is prior
to about 300 400 years ago and others do
have a more uniform layering but again
you have no way there's the other thing
I didn't mention is they tend to be
dirty you know an alpine core you can
throw a rock and hit a rock and hit
something at the surface whereas in
Greenland you know we're 500 kilometers
from the nearest rock at the surface and
so consequently they're much dirtier so
seeing volcanoes seeing detecting
volcanoes for validation of your age
scale and things like that much more
difficult than in the Alpine and then in
the the polar ice cores
which is what that might be a local
sources we're gonna redo diagram you
talked about that increase yeah you're
talking about this increase here yeah so
the historians we were milking the
publications so we stopped at 800
because this is really about classical
antiquity we do have records that go in
fact number of records that go up to the
present and that's the thing we're
working on now is trying to interpret
the Middle Ages the lead records in
Middle Ages I think most of my historian
colleague thinks this is a Charlemagne
and the something like that Kings so
there's just to show you you say you
hadn't done science in a while for me I
hadn't done history in a long time so
when I first met these guys from Oxford
and they took my hand and said they were
classicists and I tried to act like I
knew what they're talking about and as
soon as I got on some time myself I
looked up on the internet what the heck
is a class now I know now I know but
anyway that's oh yeah Charlemagne and
then the other thing is so there I think
we're gonna have to look at patterns of
course we want to get isotopes to try to
to pin it down but we're gonna have to
look at patterns including the the peat
bogs and I don't know if you noticed
earlier but now that event was in some
peat bogs and not in others and I think
what that's telling us is that I don't
think that Charlemagne after all I think
that's men dips in in Britain I think
that's led mining in in Britain but we
shall see so stay tuned
how useful are these measurements for
understanding things in the southern
hemisphere yes there's great question so
of course transporting aerosol in the
troposphere across the equator is
virtually impossible because it either
gets rained out or it doesn't circulate
in the right way you can't get some
stratospheric transport but probably not
of these things we did we did do work in
the southern hemisphere we published the
paper three or four years ago looking at
lead pollution over the last 400 years
based on an array of ice cores and you
know Brian Skinner's colleagues are
responsible for this in 1888 pollution
in antarctica turned on almost like a
light switch
it went from low levels to all of a
sudden high and that was it correlates
and the isotopes correlate exactly to
the beginning of mining and smelting in
Port Pirie in South Australia and in
literally in one year you can see it all
over Antarctica in one year it's amazing
so the other thing that's amazing is
that pollution lead pollution arrived at
South Pole 22 years before almonds and
the Scott so it's hard to imagine they
were skiing over you know clearly
polluted snow on their way there so I
guess I guess Scott was trudging and I'm
sitting was gliding along on his skis
but
locations or where the lights coming
from that certain area seems so we need
to rely this record being so distal
again we're focused on the big picture
almost not continental continental scale
but certainly are largely regional
emissions one of the reasons for that
whole coefficient of variation analysis
with the modeling the atmospheric
modeling was because I had to stop
Andrew from seeing a bump and saying oh
that's the that's the destruction of the
Roman two legions and the Teutonic
forest or something I was trying to pull
him back from to over interpreting the
record so we certainly see spikes they
whether they're just transport spikes or
maybe volcanic spikes we don't know but
the overall pattern is consistent with
with the pollution source yeah so for
instance this peak right here everybody
wants to know what that is and my guess
is is the volcano and I guess it's my
guess is it's volcanic tuff rap
[Music]
yeah great question neat certainly
people are looking at teeth and at bones
for lead and lead in those two archives
let's call them and in fact we're
working on that I was telling Joelle and
others at lunch that we're working on
that earlier in that we're working on
using our lead record to try to assess
background pollution exposure so up
until this time if you read books about
you know some people there was actually
speculation that the fall of the Roman
Empire was because of the health impacts
especially on IQ and things like that of
the elite I don't think that would you
say that's right I think that's most
people wouldn't believe that was
significant in the fall of Rome but but
I don't know not a historian but the
anyway we're interested in in the
atmospheric background level so we can
now with this modeling in these
emissions we can assess with modeling
what what the concentrations were likely
to be and assess sort of what the
background exposure to lead was was in
the general population so
epidemiological study of it but but
there are measurements of people of
bones of lead that are published in the
literature our challenge I think is
going to be finding people who are
separate from say leaded pipes or
drinking led Sweden wine and things like
that it's going to be finding that
background so this is the know the
background concentration not in addition
to any exposure you'd get through food
or or water or whatever yeah it's really
sad that in the mines I'm no those you
know the things I've read suggest that
the life life expectancy of a slave once
he entered the mines in lead mines was
six years it would have been a grisly
job and a grisly death I think so
[Music]
well so the question is about LED using
more detailed measurements of lead
isotopes to make a more detailed study
of LED provenance both during this time
period and during well both directions
right we don't certainly don't like to
do it that way in that way and one of
the reasons that we did we stopped to
the analysis here in antiquity is
because once you get over here now there
are lots and lots of sources and so we
really do need to have isotopes to help
us tease that apart the problem so I've
contacted the manufacturers of our
icp-ms is and the people who have maybe
you have a multi collector icp-ms in
this building I don't know so maybe I
should talk to somebody but anyway the
I've contacted their research groups in
hopes of getting them to try to make
measurements at these levels at very
very difficult measurements to make and
basically all the manufacturers I've
talked to have said we can't do it so
you have to go someplace else anyway
yeah we'd like we'd very much like to
we'd like we'd like we have samples
through this whole period you remember
those fraction collectors that were
built into the analytical system so we
have samples going all the way through
there that it's the same water that gets
injected to the icp-ms so we know we can
we can monitor all the count of quantum
contamination thing issues so we have
samples going all the way through this
and we'd like to run those samples for
isotopes but as I said they they say
they can't measure it so even the latest
and greatest can't measure it so I guess
the only option is going to be we're
gonna have to evaporate evaporate them
to concentrate the LED and so we and
that's the only way that's a lot more
work than just handing somebody a bomb
and running it through their multi
collector icp-ms well that's a good
question general
you know the modern transport issues but
I think you back in time the climate
system apart there's are there
simulations to try to return those are
amended aspect are we sort of just
assumed that
in our case we just assumed it was
stable and it's because you need such a
sophisticated fields and so when we
talked to
what's your name Betty Otto blazer I
think it is a 10-car you know the
uncertainties that would be associated
with trying to reconstruct fields for
this time period are much greater than
it we just wouldn't work so we're really
kind of stuck I mean the issue for this
situation was is there I mean another an
alternative explanation to this would be
is was there a major circulation change
like a change in a mock or something
like that right here right here right
here
and nothing else that we measure in the
ice cores those 35 different things we
measure none of them show anything that
suggests a climate change at that point
and to my knowledge there's no other
evidence from trees or anything else of
any significant change in circulation
but it is always an issue of course it's
always out there that maybe long-range
transport shiftin enough to actually
create an anomaly yeah so you'd be
amazed though at how few eruptions
actually have an independent historical
date on them what's the oldest do you
know what the older wealth Santorini I
guess well we don't know which eruption
it was we don't know what erupted right
at 44 44 BC yeah we know there was a
major eruption there were two and 40 we
think maybe 44 46 BC but we don't know
what their source was so but yeah
definitely whenever there are is a date
that we can compare to a radiocarbon
date or historical date we tied that to
the volcanic record and of course we
look for tough runs you tempers a little
like the is a little bit like the
provenance question you can only say
that it's consistent with this source
but you can't really say it is that
source because you could have multiple
volcanoes with reasonably close to the
same source
last minute
[Applause]
[Music]